When I say stress I know you know what I'm talking about. Everyday we hear
people talk about how stressful different things are, and the fact is we live
in a stressful world. That's why this lesson is so important and relevant to
your everyday life. It's important to understand what stress is and how to
manage our stress levels, because of the psychological and physiological fact
stress has on us. And we're going to break this lesson into three main chunks.
First, we'll talk about what stresses psychologically and the physiological
effects it has on us. Then we'll talk about different ways to deal with stress
which is what we called coping. And, at the end, we'll talk about how stress
and coping affect our health.